[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy thursday everyone and welcome to
purina with two exclamation points
as the queen of mid-morning i'm thrilled
to be hosting tonight especially since
this is obviously way past my bedtime
we begin the way all great fox news
shows begin with a fox news alert
we are reporting tonight on a missing
person 79 year old caucasian male
identifies as who
and huh
occasionally cause others jack
last seen in delaware kiwa island or
maybe the basement
wearing khakis a button-down dark
aviators and a mask dangling off his ear
and carrying the nuclear football he
answers to the name of the comeback kid
and the big guy aka your president joe
biden he also goes by scranton joe or
brandon
if you
if you really wanted his attention just
say hey who wants some ice cream
and he'll come wandering around to your
door
the media is searching for him high and
low mostly low because he falls a lot
strange right considering just last week
they told us that after a string of big
wins the president was on a roll that
his stretch of bad luck was behind him
that his poll numbers had hit rock
bottom
and like a line of parmesan cheese under
hunter's nose
there was nowhere to go but up
and that the inflation reduction act was
going to turn his presidency right
around i guess when your ekg flatlines
twice a week anything looks like a
look look at these headlines right here
and this isn't new for them they've been
hyping this all of august watch this
yeah don't look now people but all of a
sudden sleepy joe has himself a pretty
fat stack of accomplishments this big
thing on deal it is a big deal this is
huge and i don't think people understand
how big this is this has been an
extraordinarily
successful uh two years legislatively
big victory at the white house yeah it's
such a big win for president biden he's
actually interrupting his vacation and
flying back to the white house today
just for this bill signing
really big deal well the inflation
reduction act it's in the books and it's
a book that no one is buying like the
plus by greg gutfeld
and no one is buying that it will reduce
inflation the shamelessness from this
white house if we can just change the
name of a recession if we can just
convince them that despite the record
high gas prices they're paying inflation
is actually zero percent we'll be fine
well the bill will raise taxes on people
making as little as ten thousand dollars
a year in order to buy electric cars for
families making three hundred thousand
and the media just clapped along and
wrote their obedient comeback kids
stories i can't wait for the sequel
return to the basement
so brian stelzer is still clapping but
now in his own basement
[Applause]
you know between sobs and bites of
doordash he's already eaten three
drivers
speaking of eating families are paying
the highest prices in 40 years and
groceries and food they're it's so
expensive and biden is for giving the
student loan debt of soon-to-be-wealthy
doctors and lawyers
maybe it's because he's got plenty of
both
and these are all symptoms of the same
problem the latinx breakfast tacos the
gender issues the paper straws the
border buses dropping off migrants at a
four-star 700 a night hotel in new york
city it's permeating all across our
nation like monkey pox
sinking into our daily lives like an
unslightly stain on america's national
tablecloth
democrats have let their narrowest
segment of activists take leadership
control of the party and the democrats
have modeled their agenda after it their
focus went from usa to aoc within two
years
and that's my beef with all the bite and
come back stories democrats joining
other democrats to pass a bill to spend
money doubling the size of the irs and
giving money to green energy companies
that's not an accomplishment and it
doesn't do anything for the 93 of
americans who are concerned about
inflation but that's democrats based now
between 7 and 20 percent of the country
that agrees on the furthest left
nonsense and the media that treats those
kind of deals like they're solving a
climate crisis that they're not really
impacting at all
pointless policy designed by the far
left and then cheered on and validated
by the far left it's just another dem
self-licking ice cream cone
so when the media inevitably sends
reporters to truck stops and diners in
middle america this fall to see how they
got so much of the midterms wrong the
democrats should consider consider
sending a few staffers too now don't
worry staffers you won't get hurt
triggered maybe but that's exactly what
you need
have you seen that meme of the pawnshop
star guys saying the best i can do is
people are like hey we have the worst
inflation in 40 years gas prices are two
dollars higher than they should be the
border is a mess we're worried about
ukraine taiwan and the middle east our
kids have been out of school for two
years and are facing genuine challenges
and the left is like well best we can do
is electric car tax credits 87 000 more
irs agents illegal student loan debt
cancellation for harvard lawyers and a
seminar on identifying as latinx oh and
by the way i'm two-spirited so if you
criticize me the other spirit will
report you to human resources
and the poll results are in no bump for
the comeback kid more like the dead cat
bounce kid
still the media tries to put a good spin
on thing here's reuters biden approval
rises to 41 percent highest since early
june biden approval rises to 40 highest
in two months that's like saying your
horse finished last but hey at least he
finished
if a surgeon bragged he had a 41
approval rate you'd take your operation
elsewhere even to dr jill
no matter what they try though
these are the numbers that will keep the
comeback kid from getting too far like
the shock collar they put in his
underpants
from the latest nbc poll 74 say the u.s
is headed in the wrong direction what a
comeback huh best since bill de blasio's
run for congress the last time we saw
this much disapproval jerry lee lewis
married his cousin
we'll explain it later
but the sour moon is not just coming
from republicans and despite the big
comeback pronouncement several democrats
they are now distancing from the
president
it's washington's fault they set the
rules weakened our supply chain and
spiked inflation so when obama's trade
deal threatened jobs here i voted
against it and i voted with trump on
trade i don't answer to any political
party i was the only democrat to vote
against trillions of dollars of
president biden's agenda i stood up to
summon my own party and pushed to cut
the gas tax and to hire more police
officers i learned about public service
in new hampshire not washington
and others are finding reasons to wash
their hair on saturday night when they
hear biden is coming to town which only
makes him want to sniff it more
it's the least popular tour since
gutfeld joined the chippendales
the comeback kids stories were already
written in the can the media loves that
storyline when it's being said about a
democrat what say you joe
no no no i i don't need any comeback
what are you talking about
i'm here man i don't need a comeback i
do things nobody else does
did you ever try falling up a flight of
stairs
yeah
how about falling off a bike that's not
moving try it dude
i got you man you know i i recovered
from kobe like 40 times now i feel great
come on man
yeah
come back
are you talking to me
are you talking to me
that's an honest question cause if
you're not talking to me i'm talking to
myself and i don't do that jack
it's like the new york times who has
pre-written obituaries so they can be
the first to have two thousand words on
keith richards when he passes away
it's like he made a deal with satan like
you'll live forever but you'll look dead
the entire time
it's interesting though that maybe what
the media didn't realize is that the
comeback kid story actually is an
obituary at the white house it's where
good common sense policy has gone to die
in lieu of donations send your taxes
and it leaves all of the rest of us in
mourning but just for two more years
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's like caitlyn jenner people used to
call him father
fox news contributor jonathan morris
he's a tough act to follow because the
audience is usually asleep actor writer
and comedian jamie lasalle
he's the smartest person ever to leave
texas for new york hosted lawrence jones
cross country on saturday night's
lawrence jones
and as the most prominent woman on late
night tv she inspired me when i was
growing up fox news contributor cat tim
all right lawrence
the the media they try to celebrate joe
you saw like the ladies they were saying
this is this is huge this is big
but do they not realize that he's making
inflation worse no i don't think so i
mean it's quite sad um i love my dallas
cowboys i root for them every time even
if i know they're gonna end up losing
and i think that's where the media is
right now except for you have a whole
group of people that are on the
sidelines saying the president is
heading the wrong direction like just
turn around and you can make something
up this presidency i just don't think
the commander-in-chief is listening i
think the only people that he's trying
to please right now the progressive the
problem is there's not enough of them
that are gonna vote to get them across
to another term it's pretty sad maybe
they should spend time in the diners
like i do every single day talking with
people go to the barbershops america i
often say when the white diners and the
black barber shops are saying the same
thing you know we got a problem
that's a good barometer you could you
could you need to patent that one jamie
did you hear about all of this up in
alaska yeah yeah no i'm just hearing all
this now
um
yeah like am i living in an alternate
universe like the way they spin
everything you can't say gas prices are
low if like they were too high to begin
with right like i remember when i was
married my wife would always go like
we got to buy this thing from pier one
like it's 50 off and i would go yeah but
they also came up with the first price
like we don't know if that's a big yeah
but this comeback kid thinks crazy more
like come back to life kid
i was upset though because what we
learned this week was that biden did
sign off on the fbi raid i feel like
that was widely reported but in his
defense um he thought he was signing for
an amazon package
yeah he was like oh package for me i
hope it's something mushy i could eat
um
and
the nuclear codes thing to me is such bs
and so biz obviously you know they
changed the i did hear uh from a pretty
good source that biden's nuclear codes
it's zero zero zero zero zero five
because it's almost impossible to forget
your social security number
kat what do you think of the democrats
who are now trying to vote they vote
with him like 100 of the time but then
they run ads for their election saying
i'm distancing from him
yeah well i mean because he's also
distancing from everyone that's why i
feel like it does feel like he's having
a comeback every time we see him like
because we don't see him very often so
like
he's like we did he but he sets the bar
for himself very very low so if he makes
it up the stairs we're like that's
incredible
if he gets out of full sentence we're
like oh this guy's a star
um
because he sets the bar so low for
himself so every day feels like a
comeback if we actually know where he is
jonathan
how are you
are you comfortable here are you
uncomfortable
none of us should be comfortable here
because we have a former press secretary
from george bush a former priest
theology current theologian executive
coach doing a comedy show yes like none
of us should be what could go wrong but
it's so obvious
like the ridiculousness of so much
that's going on in this world right now
that it's fun to laugh at it honestly we
have to laugh at it it's good to laugh
at it and at the same time we recognize
we have a very serious issue of trust in
our leadership and we all know it's a
very serious thing and it starts with
the presidency if we have a president
who's really not running anything
and that they get a lot of stuff done
when he is not doing anything
that's that's a pretty sad situation and
we see that in a lot of parts of our
society right now and i'm glad we're
talking about these issues just real
quick jamie how do people the working
people of alaska feel about having to
pay off the student loans of people like
aoc not i mean i don't know i haven't
talked to tons of people but i would say
in general not fans
you know
like i don't know like i was talking to
somebody the other day and they were
like
i'm going to school for this like you
know you go to like regular school and
then you get you then you go like a
masters or you go to a bachelor's and i
feel like eventually the goal is to be
to have less months to live than student
loan payments
[Laughter]
well they're trying to fix that at the
white house as well hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else